Alex how are you today welcome to modern
wisdom
I'm very good how about yourself my man
yeah I'm fantastic thanks it looks an
awful lot nicer wherever you are I can
see there's a reflection of some some
good some good sunlight outside which we
haven't seen in the UK for a long time
well I live right in the beach in Venice
so I'm in a pretty opportunist pot for
weather is jealousy inducing to say the
least so we haven't got an agenda to
today we're just gonna talk about
whatever's whatever's on our mind so
what have you been what do you been
learning about or reading about thinking
about recently recently so I I got a few
things I'm working on I don't have any
real structure to my day at all I mean
like I do but I don't I basically just
write an email every day and then tweet
a lot and then just talk about stuff so
it's sort of like this personal brand
influencer strange position yeah you
can't really qualify what you do yet
people pay attention to you all the time
but uh I mean the big project may
actually working on right now that's
been constructive is I developed an
online website learning portal with a
business partner of mine called
Sovereign University to teach people how
to become sovereign individuals but then
like the modern sort of digital virtual
economy physical world as they've merged
with each other you know myself I've
been working online for myself about
going in three years and before that I'd
worked with other people and I've also
been a personal trainer for ten years
training people in person but I always
found myself attracted to sort of this
political conflict I like I like knowing
what's going on you're on the sense that
like on a medal on a meta level not just
on the level of petty politics but it
was it's been passing me the last six
seven years to watch the dialogue and
discourse devolve into this politicized
rhetoric where everything is political
and everything you say can and will be
used against you and you see people lose
their jobs or what they said you see
people you know go under fire for every
kind of comment everything is taken out
of context but new different context
yeah and I rush for someone like myself
where I because I've gone through that
vias I've gone through that myself and I
know what the consequences are
three years ago I want to be in a
position where I never had to worry
about back plus or any kind I don't want
to have to worry about an online mom I
did not want have to worry about being
doxxed I want to be immune to all that
and I rise if you work for yourself
you're a soft an individual in the sense
that you are self-made self paid
self-employed you own your own
businesses especially in digital world
where things really can't be taken from
you that way and then you have physical
basis
you're very untouchable in a certain
sense abilities so sovereign
universities sort of built around that
concept but then it's also teaching
people the fundamental skills they need
and the mindsets to learn how to do this
stuff and create high value skills and
create leverage so it's an ambitious
project that's cool you're liberating
people from the monotony of a world
where there might not be that happy at
work I was recently reading a study that
said over eighty percent of Americans
are either indifferent or actively
unhappy with their jobs and there's only
I think between eighteen and twenty
percent who are actively engaged with
their with their work yeah Society isn't
happy as a whole I mean I would say
Western societies and like as a whole I
isn't a big cultural melis that way
where everyone senses it that something
has gone wrong or things are not going
well you know whatever well means but we
all feel it like we all feel we all see
it you know within like the media itself
or everything's an outrage every day me
at the same time the world is a good
place there's a but an opportunity if
you know how to use it
capitalize on it identify it mmm but you
know I mean the job unhappiness like the
nature of work has changed over the
course of 50 60 years yeah job used to
be something that you were now a job is
just something that you do and often
times temporarily there was a whole gig
economy now where yeah how many careers
are there anymore where it's a reliable
half and you just do the same thing for
four years
that's almost non-existent at this point
I don't know that exists at all honestly
every everything has changed so you have
to be a hyper adaptive that way and for
most people where they want a set vision
of the future and this is how things
going to go you don't have anymore yeah
that again that does not exist you have
to be perceptive yet be self-aware
what do you think of the important
skills then if we're moving into this
very changeable time which I completely
agree that we are and the the old
bastions of a job for life just don't
seem to be there what what would be the
skills if someone was thinking if you
were able to design a human now that
we're gonna start at 18 years old at 21
years old what would you what skills
would you give them and what values
would you give them skill wise I would
almost approach it from a like a
classical classical liberal arts
education where the big shields been
lost in the modern areas people's will
you think yeah that's been the biggest
one people's ability to think people's
ability to express themselves you know
but how is that a skill it's a soft
skill but soft skills have hard
consequences and hard capitalization
within the modern economy so if I if I
had an eighteen year old and I want to
make them as capable as possible in the
job market or a teenager let's say
twelve like three things rhetoric logic
ability to argue ability to speak
ability to write if you can communicate
very effectively in any environment that
you're in you're always going to be near
the top I've seen that so many times as
somebody from fields that I've worked
with consulted and where the people that
can talk best are the ones that get
ahead it's be easy what is talking you
for you is communication do for you it
means you pay attention to people and
you can assess what their needs are
and if you're creating a project or even
if you're writing code or whether you're
even writing an article or if you're
just doing customer service and you're
receptive to people that is it's I mean
I'm being directly shape but that has
been lost by a lot of people because
digitization has removed human
communication yeah we're so used to
talking through text now or or showing
an image but then you get people face to
face and you see how awkward they are
trumbo yeah yeah so that those people
that can speak on camera those people
that can talk at length those people
where they can those people worry they
can have a conversation someone they
know how to listen just doing those
three things you can identify so many
opportunities within the digital economy
and even in the real world economy you
know social media now has become such a
big market for businesses any even
online is well the same thing is basic
stuff like copywriting
web copy our co-writing yeah that's
essentially with search engine
optimization as on a metal level so yeah
those those three are baby being able to
speak write argue let's say say for
persuade that's why I would start with
you know with a young person yeah and
then from there it'd be more sort of
like tangible you could say skill sets
like knowing how to build a website
knowing how to take good photos knowing
just basic yeah business rithmetic in
math the way the way modern education is
set up where you go to college and you
learn all this information and then you
go to let's say some kind of job and
then you have to relearn everything
again let's get that completely
backwards yeah I said this the other day
on Twitter where yeah I think in the
next probably year to 10 years to 20
years what you'll see is sort of this
return of apprenticeship where people
get out of high school they go work
hustle jobs or they'd go work paid
internships and they develop these
necessary skills and then maybe they go
back to school for a specific education
to augment that yeah that that's how I
would set up and if I had you know a kid
now that's why I be telling them to do I
would not be telling them go to college
you know you'll you'll find yourself a
college that no you won't
you're gonna be made to take two years
of worthless GE classes you're gonna be
in a room with 100 people you're
probably taught by ta you'll switch
majors four times yeah there's not net
time getting to the quality of education
which has precipitously declined so yet
I that's campuses [ __ ] like a [ __ ] show
at this point love to say so I did five
years at Newcastle University here in
the UK finished with the master's in
international marketing and I became
incredibly disenfranchised and
disenchanted with academia as I moved
through that and me and my business
partners sat next to each other in our
first ever seminar and pretty much from
that day we started working together and
now almost 13 years later I've still not
got rid of him and yeah we um I was
being shown a world of business in
academics which was saying one thing and
then I was experiencing one in the real
world which essentially bore very little
resemblance and I think the time that I
was doing it as well was very crucial
because this was 2006
to 2010 and that was so I did a business
management course then international
marketing masters and there was not a
single course on social media for the
entire time that I was there and that's
like 2006 was when you still needed a
university address to be able to sign up
to Facebook yeah do you remember that
you had to have like a like a the
correct suffix to your at edu I think
odd for the UK dot a seed or a you yeah
exactly so yeah we got that and then you
think like magic like you're doing your
marketing course now and no one anywhere
mentioned social media you want your
money back because it's just that a
massive selling shot so I think that
you're right I think that these soft
skills that ones that are difficult to
to acquire but they're definitely the
ones that are scalable right and it
doesn't matter what happens to the
market if you can sell and you can
communicate so I did it I did a podcast
the other day with a guy called Leon
Scott from the UK and afterwards he
commented on the fact that it was the
first time that he's had a one-hour
conversation with someone way we've
completely focused on just what was
being said the the content that we were
going through
no one obviously no one has the phone
now no one's you know even looking
looking anything else other than to
gesture or to remember and I think that
like having someone to practice
conversing with it sounds so bizarre
that you need that but people people in
need I mean I agree like that's it
that's the quality of like the quality
of focus yeah I get asking that question
constant all the time like yeah how do I
focus better how do I study better and I
was a natural what I never really
studied much at all
I was always this I have a very good
memory that's not what I was not the
person that was like a good study or
where I was studious that way I was not
I was a terrible student all through
high school
adolescence college I did the bare
minimum to get by because I didn't I
never saw the point in doing something
just the sake of doing it that way which
seemed to me to be the reason for
education but that quality focus now I
could ask that question a lot by young
guys young gentlemen and late teens late
20s even even lady followers and it's
always same thing like how do I focus
better and I was tell
focus is just doing one thing at a time
like that that's it it doesn't happen
there's not complicated definite you're
doing one thing and one thing only you
having a conversation you're making eye
contact with somebody it's through
screen and you're just you're talking
you're not looking at this looking at
that clicking this clicking that Walter
and Carrie I'm like it's one thing you
know what about that so difficult yeah
but we live we live in this culture now
where people pride themself so much on
will say tasking the ability to switch
through apps and switch through devices
and their attention is constantly going
to the next thing and the next thing and
next thing the next thing and I realize
it trains your thinking to not be able
to think it's very fractured and you
know as a not to deliver a sub story but
I am on the receiving end I'm like I
feel that I am patient zero for someone
who's been able to see this so I was
elated late adopter of an iPhone I was
still holding onto the hope that
Blackberry was gonna be good until maybe
five years ago something like that which
is a shame because he you know I missed
the buttons I genuinely genuinely do I
mean yeah and bbp and I'm gonna change
your BB pin every time you got a new
handset so what I've noticed is that I
was a voracious reader when I was
younger I did a number of degrees again
without a smart device that was as
attention-grabbing
as an iPhone is now or a similar device
and my capacity for low stimulus
activities ie things like reading like
deep reading has had and is still so
heavily damaged that it is it's not even
comparable the way that I'm able to
focus my attention doesn't even feel the
same now and I've had to construct this
hilarious series of instantiation
initiatives as James clear from atomic
habits would implementation initiatives
it's James clear would call it where so
no phone in the bedroom phone is in its
outside because I can't have it in here
because if I'm working that's that if
I'm at work there's a special drawer
where the phone lives that goes in my
desk like I've got my morning routine
has very specific like order of things
that I go through because I'm like
having a create
the equivalent of like a toddler's
environment way you know you've got the
little foam cups that go on the sharp
edges of all of the the set of drawers
and the desks and stuff I've had to
create I've had to create myself an
attention equivalent of that because I
essentially am a child who can't be
trusted with technology anymore
and for me to relearn this deep work the
sort of Cal Newport approach to it this
single focus onto one particular topic
at one time I'm having to essentially
place myself in a hermetically sealed
environment why there's no danger of
distraction so I can you know for the
guys that are listening who maybe do
struggle with the focus I can completely
empathize with what they're going
through to sympathize with it yeah
that's funny because it recently the
past I guess past two years I realized I
did the least amount of reading I've
ever done but yeah one level I got the
most done it ever gotten done so it
wasn't as if that you know I was at a
loss but at the end of last year right
you know what I probably read about
three books last year like incompletion
like that was it that was it and I want
to get back to reading so that was my
that was a news resolution this year I
told myself I'm gonna read a book a week
like I used like I used to
umm yeah it's been it's ministering
because now like I so I started reading
I got publish books in my bed like right
here like I read this let's grab it yeah
I read this book last week Empire to
summer moon
it's about Comanche tribe and the United
States a great fascinating like
phenomenal book I read it like this
awesome awesome book nonfiction yeah you
have a few others so I'm at like five
for the year so far so I'm I'm on trip
Yemen but the experience of reading
again where I was just you know I had
days like I've had days where I just I'm
in my room the entire day just reading
the whole book yeah you know four four
five six hours like getting a whole book
this okay done on to the next one yeah
it's strange because it feels good and
like the read the process of reading it
is actually very relaxing there's a
there's a mental nourishment to it when
I do get back on the device now or the
computer there's a harshness to it and
there's service like this a farcical
rapidity where you're just going through
everything school you're scrolling the
feet over and over and over again
refresh refresh refresh refresh and
you're trying to you know you're spying
everything at once
and it's not overwhelming this sounds
like I'm so bummed by it but it feels
fake yeah and there's a subset there I
rice is just lack of thought to it
there's sort of this lack of deep
thought deep focus to it where elephant
it just it's training you could think on
such a superficial level and you see
that with how people communicate with
each other we're all arguments now all
headlines all article to everything it's
all written in emotional sound bites
yeah there's very little of facts reason
context it's just written to get your
attention fire up your emotions get you
pissed off or confirm your biases and
then move on to the next thing and you
can do that a thousand times a day
mm-hmm we're not built to have this
level of stimulus go through us I don't
think not at all and there was a article
that I read not so long ago that said
something to do with the amount of
stimulus that a typical human account is
now in a single day is the equivalent to
the level of stimulus that a our
Paleolithic ancestors would have done in
a month any like right okay so that's
the level to which my dopamine is being
hacked by devices and you totally
correct so the listeners will know that
we are evangelists of a good morning
routine on this show and mine is it is
beautifully - my favorite part the day
by by an absolute country mile if I've
not had to work I run the night clubs if
I've not had to work the night before
and I've been able to go to bed at the
time I want which is ten and get up at
the time I want which is six my morning
is is beautiful it's smoothie some
meditation some reading some journaling
some gratitude some deep work then some
rom watts or some yoga then I might you
know and I'm sure I've finished that and
I'm like that is if I could choose a day
I would just I'd have an entire day
there's a morning routine and it almost
feels laborious to think I as soon as I
step out of that door that bedroom door
I now need to enter what I feel like the
real world and start playing the game of
here we go and I like sometimes I work
myself up to checking my phone and I
think my my particular device given the
industry I'm in and and the way that we
work have a lot of staff and there's a
lot of group chats on what's happened
there's a lot of social media going on
so maybe I have a
super normal level of super normal
stimulus but yeah this some days were
like this the equivalent of working up
to a 1 rep max I need to prep myself
before I pick the phone up it's my
girlfriend I tell her sometimes now
since I'll be looking at my phone I get
I just said I because it's Twitter
following I have then like the email
list and he also doesn't mean accounts
it's just a constant
you know torrent of notifications and
just the Maharaj
yeah and I'll look and be like ah like
someone else wants a piece of my time
and I think I right I read an article
recently I think it might been on
BuzzFeed or maybe it was not it was
about millennial burnout and the article
is quite insightful there were people of
course commenting that this is this is
[ __ ] this article Millennials just
week I'm like but there was something
very real to the effect that Millennials
the writer elucidating miss very clearly
letting else deal with this environment
of such overwhelming simulation like we
just sell the time and there's so many
things grabbing our attention and every
task takes at another piece of it every
task takes its a piece of it and at the
same time we have a socio-economic
pressure of trying to just survive and
people have the socio-economic pressure
will they ever be able to get ahead and
then you have you know you have all
these factors or you're dealing with
that doing simple things like getting
back to somebody on the phone or having
to respond to an email or head and go
send a package is laziness or it's just
that you cannot do another thing you
know be like we are so driven out
towards this god of efficiency or
anything has to be efficient and
optimized and fast in speed but then we
do all that but does it make our lives
better in the sense that we actually get
more done or actually just having this
Derby's like death by a thousand cuts
pin pricks totally totally correct yeah
like is it and you have to drop
something off you're like I don't feel
like doing that cuddle I can't go to
post office it's too much today mm-hmm
it's like um I keep on thinking what
you're talking about that about ramming
a computer and it's that you still have
the same total amount of RAM but that
the number of tasks that it's trying to
do at one time is now
you know 10x hundred X thousand X and
switching between
it's just so exhausting I am I wouldn't
wanted to ask someone who works in the
industry similar to yourself my personal
brand is a big deal this for quite a
while how do you draw the line between
when you're doing work and when you're
being wasteful on social media because
there's always that excuse right oh well
if I just do if I spend another X amount
of time on Twitter maybe I'll find
something which I quote tweet or retweet
or reply to and that bangs and that adds
another hundred subs on to the this
channel or the that email list how do
you how do you try and control that so
this is gonna be like a sort contrarian
sideways perspective I I don't control
it but I have a different model how I
see this so my backgrounds the fitness
industry that that's where I start I've
been approached here for 10 years and I
when I got online when I got in Facebook
about 2007 I was in those for the
Facebook Fitness community for a long
time people do you know 16 I delete
facebook over a year ago well over a
year ago but what I still happened for
people as they try to develop their
brand like this idea of a personal brand
to now that has like become very
preeminent where because we are in such
a search for truth and authenticity and
we no longer trust institutions and I
like first news you don't risk
government we don't trust authority
figures so we're looking for individuals
that we can serve half be our digital
friends and we'll trust them because
it's a one-to-one interaction so I saw
people doing some finished industry you
know years ago before personal branding
even became a hot term you know I
realize that those people that had the
healthiest relationship with their
audience and had the healthiest
relationship with these these tools
these platforms they didn't obsess over
the value they delivered on daily basis
they didn't obsess for proactivity they
tried to be consistent and what they
presented to the best of their abilities
and then those things that were not in
alignment with the brand or in alignment
with the domain that they were working
in they didn't worry about it because
they had the perspective that you know
what I'm human I am NOT just one thing I
am any things so I'm just going to show
essentially my personality as it is
yeah and whether you connect whether or
not that's upon you so I've said this
before many times if you want to have a
really good relationship with your
audience with your work
you have to be fully invested in on the
sense that you want to be consistent
value but you have to be detached from
it in regards to the outcome that gives
you it's a difficult position to be in
right very paradoxical like so it's
almost like sort of paradox that like to
be really what if you want to love
people then you also have to be able to
hate them an equal measure you can't
only be one it has to be both so that's
that's how I working now so I do a basis
if I as ideas come into my head and you
know thanks sighs yeah I'll share them I
think there would be times where I'll
just be in a humorous mood you know
snappy mood and I'll just I'll tweet
whatever I feel like yeah it'sit's work
for the it I recent realized from in
reasons working people see you even they
realize you're not trying to be serious
all the time you're not try to present
yourself just one thing you have flaws
you are person you're not you're not a
bot you're not you're not boring mm-hmm
if you're selling on personality that
way that's highly highly highly
effective yeah and on a certain metal
level at the highest levels of any
industry the people that are most
successful are the ones who have that
kind of power personality utility right
I mean as a good example Elon Musk forty
million for I think it's about twenty
million followers of forty million
followers
SpaceX like four million and he deleted
he deleted
Tesla's Facebook yeah like Cristiano
Ronaldo thirty to forty million real
madrid twelve million like people
connect with people they don't connect
with brands yes and you can do the
mistakes that you make like imagine if
imagine if Real Madrid started tweeting
stuff with typos in and all like you
know accidentally putting up just random
bits of content and stuff like that
everyone what you're doing you're
supposed to be this professional but you
can get away with that when you're a
person that's definitely an asymmetry in
the delivery of in the ability to
deliver a message between personal brand
and corporate brand I use this I use
this I example when I was trained
personal trainers were like the term
personal trainer what's the first word
in it it's personal so you should be
personable well the people you train and
it's a two humans having a conversation
and you're trying to help them and
they're teaching you something
trainer part comes second yeah and I
would say that because you know for a
lot of trainers where people get into
these very prescriptive dogmatic
mindsets as to how they're supposed to
interact what they're supposed to say
they want to fit people in the boxes and
like that that's not what is there is no
prescription there's no ultimate
philosophy there's no magic solution
it's speaking to people's individuals
you know you are human being they're
human being it's personal first and then
you train them second
yes I'll even personal branding are you
a person who has a brand that has
coalesced around you or are you this
sort of contrived brand and you're
trying to be personable through that
brand you know that the former people
will take to the ladder they'll think
you're boring or just really just full
of [ __ ] or a sociopath yeah Steve online
all the time or people people will turn
on their their guru or their you know
whoever they idolized after a while
because they rise it's just the same
repetitive message and there's no real
death to it they're just basically being
this ad hoc yeah take yourself I get
that with Tai Lopez like I you know Tai
Lopez for me now I I don't know what
I've clicked on but that man is pixeled
me hard and I'm getting retargeted like
it mastered every form of social media
that I log onto it's like it's like the
Tai Lopez machine now like when I go on
and a lot of a lot of his stuff like Tai
if I see another video of you telling me
in front of a jet or in front of a
Lamborghini or in in your garage about
how people need to start working online
I'm like man like it just it is the lost
an awful lot of that authenticity in my
opinion I totally get what you mean that
oh well that's a good example too I
talked about this in an email last night
where I called it sort of like predatory
capitalism which so I mean I say say
that I can't let me do some context
so-so capitalism you know as a as an
idea as a concept obviously you could
say it's done a great good for the world
you know free markets you know the
ability to you know nobody to earn you
know like everyone having you know the
equal opportunity at least you creating
power to you know to have their work
valued Mariotti show and so forth but
you know like like any system like any
idea there's always negatives to
anything and I was using the term last
night
predatory capitalism I was referring to
the fire festival which remember two
years ago wasn't this spectacular
massive failure the sort of like peak
apogee of millennial narcissism and the
desire for beauty and envy and wanting
to be known and wanting to be where the
action is living for living for the gram
with more Instagram I was talking about
the fire festival and the guy that came
up with it Billy McFarland and I said
this is a guy's an examples for petrol
capitalism and sociopaths II where he
created this a critical idea for the
festival he wanted to live in this
experience but his actual regards for
the people that signed up he didn't
regard anybody he's being valuable at
all because he just doesn't he doesn't
because he is legit me sociopathic and
you know even after the fire festival
ended and very like hardly anyone got
refunded and everyone lost money he was
still using that email list he had from
everyone that had bought tickets and he
was saying them fake offers for other
tickets other fake offers for concert
tickets fake off or offers for going to
be a Beyonce and jay-z and he's trying
to get cash out of them and like it is
that capitalism like yes it is like he's
trying to earn money and he has an email
list like absolutely is
but is it exploitation of people like
100 percent exploited you see that now
with within the personal branding realm
and even on like the larger realm of
like um pits or a big food Big Pharma
the oil good opioid crisis in the United
States where this motivation for profit
at any cost
yeah and you know with complete
disregard for the human cost and then
the argument well you know it's making
money it's creating it's grating jobs or
like you know that someone's profiting
from that like that's great yeah but for
someone like ty Lopez like I even
against AI Lopez obviously I seems like
he has helped people like what you just
said you realize like you know what like
as soon as I get marked within your
whatever your social media network web
is I'm just another target for you to
hopefully eventually get some cash out
of yeah so I'm keep getting ads over and
over again I keep seeing your stuff over
and over and over again like this ty
Lopez really care maybe he does maybe he
thinks that's a good thing I don't know
but if he does if he does it's not
coming across which is the issue like
you know like if I can sense if
someone's trying to sell me something
and I get the sensation that they don't
care they either are being willfully
neglectful of my
feelings as a potential customer of
theirs or their [ __ ] and naive about
what their messages that's coming across
and I don't want to be coached by either
of those people so you know that but I
mean to go back to the fire festival
thing man I have watched that twice the
Netflix documentary I know that I know
we said on Twitter I was gonna try and
hack a hulu version but I haven't been
able to do that and I what I want to I
yeah yes Gabe Prieto is is there any new
information or is it just said that sort
of it was really insightful I did not
expect to watch the documentary at all I
remember when I was on Twitter you know
two years ago and the fire festival went
down on Twitter and I was never it was a
pylon and everyone was like making fun
of it are these stupid rich kids that
cheese sandwich photos which yeah so
like it was funny and I remembered it
and I couldn't tell you why I actually
watched the first documentary I think I
was just yeah I know why I was talking
about my girlfriend and she had no idea
what the fire castle was so she she's
very sure of out of the loop on like
social medias stuff which is great she
sounds Pandya oh we should watch the
documentary like oh you know you can see
what it is
she works in the text she actually works
in tech and she has a company but you
know she's served like she manages to
see how the loop of the dealy whatever
Twitter she's like well the balance
right we need to eat we need to know
yeah we need to get her to prescribe us
a digital at the digital reduction
method I'll ask her but uh so guys
that's why we watched the fire castle
documentary and I watched it it was
actually quite fascinating because yeah
I just assumed it was me this music
festival I went down and I went down
playing Taha but it started actually as
this idea for an app which was a very
legitimate idea where Billy McFarlane
the guy who was the the entrepreneur he
had this idea that what if you could
book talent directly through like one
network needed to go through middlemen
so it was very similar actually twit
Jerry Weintraub did in 1970s Jerry
Weintraub for background context he was
an American band
talent manager in the 1970s and he was
known for changing music industry where
he signed up a gazillion acts under his
management company he had like that led
Zeppelin Frank Sinatra are very big
names and then rather than when he would
go and do tours with his talent
rather than have to negotiate with like
the middlemen promoters in different
areas across the United States he would
go directly to the theater where the
show would be held and this was a big
idea back 1970s and he negotiated the
venue so he was taking you know he was
still a middleman he's like you know
rather than have to add another step I
got the talent let's just go talk we're
going to perform and that was it
so the idea for the fired festival it
was actually supposed to be promotion
for an app where if you want to book one
you want to book job you want to look at
Rihanna for your birthday party you
could just open up the app her booking
fee was right there you it take you
directly to her agent
I'm you'd have like put down the money
like you know deposit and you know it
was supposed to done take steps
transaction so the fire festival started
this idea like that we'll use this from
up the app and then the guys billing
Farley and Ja Rule's the other one who
is sort of the height man for this
project they got to the Bahamas and then
they just had this idea to this fly in
like the top 20 models in the world and
the you know spent a lot of money doing
this and let's just film ourselves
partying for a bunch of days and then
we'll try and make like some sort of
sizzle reel out of it and that became
the fire crustal documentary and they
never expected it to work at all but
then when it became popular in the rise
okay we got something lets us launch
this festival tell me you talked about
getting in way over your head yeah so
seeing that happen and seeing like every
human misstep along the way of trying to
do this grand project it was like never
got the ground and it was like doomed
from the start but then you also serve a
service all the power personality where
the guy Billy despite everything
breaking down every single day beside
being behind a money and like the Friday
and prodding people and not paying
people and just like every everything
they could go wrong did go wrong I get
was like Browns you know servile uh well
that way he's still managed to make it
happen because he just was so like a
missus were sociopaths he's a good thing
he was so determined that nose will work
I swear to God everybody's kind of went
along its personnel baby it's like you
know Billy says it's gonna work so you
know I know it's not it's it's failing
haven't paid in four months but screw it
let's just do it anyway it's this
something I'm so conflicted about him
right and my my appreciation of this and
for the club promoter
listening as well they will don't know
it's rare that we have something that's
talked about our industry and this was
one and it could promote his worst
nightmare like and we've all you know we
were in weekly Club nights we've had
I've done a thousand events probably
over my career and you know there's
times we've opened a club in New Castle
where the painters were still painting
the toilets while customers were going
in and we were hoping because it had
just opened and we were we were hoping
no one would need the toilet for like
the first 15 minutes because then that
means that the painters could have
finished and we've we've we've done ones
where we've had to get like a generator
in because the power had been cut off
because the bill hadn't been paid and
stuff and you like right okay like this
is you know this is you can relate yeah
I can relate on a slightly deeper level
I've got that that degree of anxiety but
you totally write the Billy MacFarlane
character I'm so conflicted about
because there is there's something so
seductive and and romantic and admirable
about someone who has this single-minded
purpose and he's able to to follow
something through like that the
difference is he wasn't doing it from a
place of passion he was doing it from a
place where he wanted the status and he
wanted the money and he wanted all the
stuff that's associated with it but
because naturally especially in this
world were so drawn to success like
success is this it is the zenith on the
hill of of what everybody wants in this
world and here's the thing that a friend
said to me a few weeks ago and I can't
get out at my head the Billy mcFarland
his virtue and his integrity was
basically non-existent throughout the
whole festival the whole project all he
wanted to do was look cool on his grand
of a scale as possible and the only
reason that anybody on the planet is
slating him or that the vast majority of
people are slating him is because it
didn't work now if all of the Stars had
aligned and that guy his operations
director or whatever had sucked a [ __ ]
of the customs guy and got the water out
and
and then you know somehow they'd managed
to get some villas and maybe I hadn't
been that weekend where the population
doubled for like basically yacht week
and maybe the food had arrived and maybe
the catering had worked in blah blah
blah let's say that in a different set
of random circumstances another
iteration of this particular festival
everything had come together correctly
but none of it had been due to
preparation it was just a more look upon
look upon look and somehow maybe they'd
petered out like a six out of ten seven
out of ten festival we would be hailing
this guy as the new festival creator on
the planet we would the difference the
only difference between iteration one in
the real world and iteration two that
we're talking about here is the fact
that it didn't work so we're so seduced
by success or any costs that we forget
you'd be like yeah but doesn't matter
about his virtues man like look like he
you know he knew it was gonna be okay in
the end any like right but does the ends
justify the means and did a means other
means justifying the value his values
that's a very good question like I don't
have I don't have an answer I have to
think about that myself and the thing
with the Hulu documentary which I mean I
would suggest watching it since the Hulu
document goes more into the psychology
of like himself like he's interviewed a
lot more right the festival ending and
you goes more his personal history and
like sir how he started as an
entrepreneur where he was like in
kindergarten and he can charge the girl
like one dollar for like fixing her
crown that like I was I was his first
entrepreneurial endeavor where he blew
he Tom self how to code like on this
1999 computer and hacked his school
network and southest message that I'll
fix everybody's crowns for a dollar I'm
not kidding Wow yes instinct like yeah a
very young age she's obviously quite
quite brilliant that way yeah and then
later on in college it showed his sort
of like entrepreneurial you know you
know projects you know which some of
which failed maybe be New York you want
to you know create something important
but his his first project nieces which
he had also highlighted where he created
this credit card company which is
actually fraudulent but he made it
it was interesting though because like
you said it shows like its success any
cost and he's still got a head despite
this for a very long time but yeah it
makes me questions for his
entrepreneurial mindset that some people
have something in Silicon Valley were
like move fast and break things fail
fail fail I'm like what are the human
consequences of doing this you know like
in his first case he was never really
truly successful I would say like his
first business did he get venture
capital yeah he did did the people that
bought the cards get what they were
promised no they never did but he still
managed to walk away with money okay
yeah when the fire festival looked like
that cool duck amigos more much more
much more to like the inception of it
like the nitty gritty details from the
very beginning that was this very doomed
idea like every step of the way we're
like there was it wasn't just like
series of like oh this is kind of a good
problem it was this is a red flag this
can't get done we're gonna have to
either lie to people rip them off or do
both yeah well it's okay you Obi's we
need to be solution aware he did yeah
yeah you see you see these
entrepreneurial cliches all time it's
all about solutions like we you know we
gotta sell the problem we gotta sell the
problem yeah you know let's not talk
about problems talk about solutions and
like it like it so he goes through this
and then later on he's being interviewed
and like you know comparing versus like
his you know court transcripts and he's
still compulsively lying and he doesn't
have any sense even is he still couples
to be lying like what he said this but
then you're saying this right now
yeah you can see Sir yeah you can see
the cognitive dissonance that people
have the art would you be sociopathic
where they they're caught in a lie but
they can't even acknowledge it's like
one's the truth yeah like they don't
they don't even know yeah um you know be
like again what you said like woof he
had successfully done it I'm like to
have done that it would have taken a
more you know sort of like psychopathic
person that had some sense of
consciousness like he this is the messed
up I mean I was thinking about this I'm
like man I wonder if I could pull this
idea off like in LA like I was thinking
about this because it was a great idea
was yep like it was amazing idea that
the marketing for it was so brilliant
especially the the use of the models was
the biggest thing like I feel like that
was overlooked
where what did it take to make that fire
festival campaign a success they got the
twenty most people in the world the big
followings they had them post an orange
tile
and then just because people wanted
proximity to beautiful women they want
to be where beautiful women were because
there to be a beautiful woman it's a
woman that everyone wants to be and it's
a woman that every man wishes he could
have like that is so desired and
sub-level beauty is purely authentic
because we can't truly fake it we can
try but we can't fake it yeah so like
our models are sort of like this
unknowing agent for truth in a certain
way then they may have no depth at all
there's nothing to them but because
they're beautiful well at least I know
that's real so people signed up for it
and like their people spend thousands of
dollars to be there with the hopes that
they're gonna be able to be next to
somebody who's a 10 and they can take a
photo with her and say look at me and
who I'm with and yeah I'm important now
like my existence has been validated
yeah yeah how do you pull that off like
my god but like could it be pulled off I
think it honestly could except now
everyone's gonna be self aware it's like
just another fire festival yeah let's
say well you it's a it's you can pull
that switch once and any time which it
which sucks actually because had that
have worked the kisses influence
marketing to big industry at the moment
as it is but had that have worked you
would have had this hyper influencer
marketing there would have been a new
market that would have opened up and you
know like Kendall Jenner's doing her own
things but you know like those kind that
a shelana of influencer would be you
know would there be the new opening of a
particular casino that was in
association with them and you know yes
yes I man the whole documentary just
completely blew my mind and let us say
having been having watched a number of
failed festivals much smaller but
watched a number of failed festivals
over the years I it's it takes a very
special level of bone headedness and
single mindedness to even believe that
you can create a festival on an island
like 'i try to make the perfect example
and they say in miami like you have
Ultra Music Festival which is one of the
biggest best festivals on the planet
best liner and even that is a
Mystikal nightmare and these guys were
wanting to do it somewhere with like no
bio waste disposal no running water no
air conditioning you like I can't work
out if it's a love of the idea that drew
them through the obstacles are an
ignorant to the obstacles in terms of
Billy and Ja Rule as well that ja Rule
doesn't get enough stick in the Netflix
documentary it's like once it's all gone
down you'll remember this scene and
they're in the conference room and it's
got like it must be from like Google
like Google hangout and they've got all
the little faces across the bottom of
the screen and Ja Rule's in there going
like no listen guys like you know
everybody has setbacks man and then a
uses some inane pithy example and you
like listen ja Rule may honestly like
you just need to go back to making music
because you are shite at business and
you're just getting in the way of people
who have had a potentially profitable
app ya know I remember that he's like
what was the example he's like nobody
died no one's in jail so like we're all
fine I'm like there are times as
appropriate in there it's not
appropriate
I felt bad you know for the guys that
designed like the software for this app
which yeah probably yeah it looks good
and they're all out of a job never got
paid and now they're the thing that
project they worked on that might have
been totally viable have done a smaller
skill that's it's all gone lost yeah
especially considering that that was the
project it was a good idea it's like
it's like someone saying let's launch
this particular car and then one guy on
the board decides to open up like an ice
cream store that happens to have like
Class A drugs in the ice cream but to
promote the car and then the car gets
scrapped and you're like [ __ ] save me
but yeah the guys who make that happen
you know again coming from a code
promotes perspective it's difficult to
book talent you know it we're fortunate
in the UK that Vodou events the company
that I own we have good connections and
existing relationships with these
Booker's put people like BIGBANG and and
and other large booking agencies know
who we are and we have a contact
in there we'll get preferable rates and
but if you are a new fledgling festival
or club night or even like a you know 16
year-olds dad who wants a run a birthday
party or something like that I like
trying to book big talent is a nightmare
so there was 100 100 percent a gap in
the market for that digitalized version
of the guy from the 70s that you said
once long shot like an eBay for for the
best talent on the planet like if you
could book and imagine the downstream
effects of that like you would have an
awful lot more festivals and startups in
terms of events going on the artists you
know how many more times would blink-182
get booked if people knew how easy it
was to book blink-182 like you know
they'd be getting deposits all the time
Oh constantly constantly
that's guy I know I've been thinking
with that like that was a very
legitimate good idea
iíve had some proximity the Arrington
mystery being in Los Angeles and working
in Hollywood and that's it's this very
constant old nightmare of okay let's try
again hold this person how do we hold
this person all right well contact this
person first and sweet-talk them go
maybe talk to this person second in the
new yeah sweet talk may pay them and
then maybe they'll pass on a message
like a third person and maybe that third
person might have like some direct line
access to the talent who maybe will get
back to them who maybe will call you
yeah but only he taught like it like
it's just this the stars need to align
so well right yeah and so I mean so much
it comes down to almost just luck where
it's like okay hopefully I kind of
hoping this works out hoping this works
out yeah I I wonder if that will happen
at some point since it seems like I
especially for especially for talent
let's say the people are up and coming
they're trying to sort of like but you
know become known be seen you know
develop like their own you know develop
your presence that way you know for like
lower-level mid-level acts that could be
very revitalizing for their career in a
certain level because like I wonder how
much of I want to see success it makes
you question how much of a success is
not just from like a talents lack of
hustle but from just like a lot of this
of this poor man accessibility yeah I
mean that's a very calm thing in
Hollywood to like that if you haven't
that manager you know about agent you
might have missing opportunities all the
time and you have no idea
mm-hmm yeah I get that I didn't know
that most of the people didn't get
refunded it's not the case there are
some people got there like I think
they're like the people that lower-level
tickets they got their money back but
they're what like some other things that
came out was like like the rich like the
wrist band yep that was an RS ID payment
no that was refunded actually since they
he's still like he got sued for it's
been called like 25 million dollars yeah
I don't like that some of that money was
never funded at all yeah I mean even
that wristband was a cash grab because
they had to pay off other stuff from
other loans he taken out so yeah that
was the apparently there's that guy on
the Netflix documentary who says that
there was a woman who rang him
aggressively saying that he hadn't
loaded up his wristband yet and it would
appear that the the tickets were maybe
like three to five thousand pounds and
then they were being suggested to put
almost that amount again yeah wristbands
so they could do jet ski hire and
alcohol this and all the rest of it so
what what happened because he didn't
have he didn't have festival insurance
no what is the the situation moving
forward with getting that money out I
mean you know he's in jail which is I
mean like do not pass go do not collect
200 pounds like that is jail is the that
no one's getting debt out of you in jail
I'm going to presume that they will have
gone through they lived on his forensic
accounts and they'll have gone through
every asset he has with a fine-tooth
comb and once you've sold off like a
couple of bottles of Sirach and probably
some ship heads of lebu tons like what's
left that was so I react after watching
the second riser I did a bit of research
essentially like nobody got paid like I
mean like almost nobody got paid like a
lot of people a lot of people like the
Bahamian workers no one got their money
back
yes Peter reason being that when they
even went before the festival ever was
like an idea and they were just on the
island filming he basically ran a Ponzi
scheme of just debt where he got capital
one person you know are short-term loans
and then the next round of funding would
pay off the first round and the next
round would pay off the second round
so like when it what everything was
accounted for
with forensic analysis there was no
money anywhere because like it doesn't
it didn't exist
he got $500,000 spent all of it and then
got alone $500,000 you know telling the
other guy don't worry you'll get the
money back eventually like it's going
towards something so there was nothing
to you know even how its term looking
for there's nothing to liquidate yeah
really this was nothing so it kind of
just evaporates into thin air because
there'll be some things that they won't
have be able to being able to get on
credit so they'll have had to have paid
deposits for instance for some of the
artists they literally won't have been
able to book them without that and
there's certain things that we'll have
needed to have been paid upfront the
Instagram models and the guys who made
the video and people like that like this
especially the early stuff so I guess
the early people get paid and then
there's just it's like this this black
hole vacuum that's just sucked Oh
everybody's money from both sides so
you've sucked up money from one side and
time or resources from the contributors
side I think the only ones that seem to
have gotten paid like for sure with us
the models that was it okay yeah yeah
like that was everybody else like they
weren't getting paid the or they're
getting paid for acne like never got
back with that we're over at all yeah I
mean him and he burned through money
it's just insane rate himself because he
was you know like he bought a freaking
Bugatti for a million dollars be out the
alcohol bill his dining out bill his his
paying for everything while no one was
actually getting paid so yeah yeah it's
a that's an important situation but I
mean it was interesting too that you can
see how like debt you can just keep this
allocating it somewhere else over and
over again to stay ahead of it but you
don't be eventually it will catch up to
you yeah but you can't keep going back
to the same investors and still trying
to fundraise from your own customers
yeah eventually runs out there's a
there's a thing that's been going
through my head
some Harris in his book waking up talks
about an individual I think it was in
the states in the 70s or the 80s who
began partway through his life to have
this compulsion for aggression really
severe compulsion for aggression and I
think he went upon to a bell tower and
started shooting random people
note saying that something needs to be
looked at about myself then killed
himself and potentially even killed his
family as well and when they did an
autopsy on him they decided to conduct a
thorough one on his brain and they found
that there was a tumor which was
affecting his amygdala which i think is
what mediates aggression in people and
it was literally like someone pressing
the aggression button in your brain so
this guy's free well essentially had
been taken away from him and I wonder if
Billy McFarlane has a entrepreneurial
equivalent of this like he's he's got
this like hustle button the hustle is
just it's like Gary Vee is standing on
his neck like the entire time just going
like grind hustle drying hustle I can't
believe it I can't believe I mean I've
met ya I've had some experience in the
tech space I mean I've met people like
that where they are just they have to
constantly be creating selling something
and it is it is the essence of their
being and they can't not be doing that
mmm and they can't really tell you why
they need to it's just a compulsion for
them they just you know yeah it's weird
right because if we're in an industry
yourself and me we are self-employed our
value is derived from how hard we work
and how much we do get on that hustle
but I've there's limits to it there's
the the psychic I have a safety a safety
catch in place where if it was three
days before Festival and someone had
made a website detailing the fact that I
had like Hurricane Katrina storm tents
outside or whatever it was as and there
was no water and I I'm asking the ops
director to suck off the man who does
the customs thing and I'm just like nah
I would have that would have been a
point at which I mean long before there
but I would have had to pull the plug
but there is a lack of that the puzzle
buttons getting depressed so hard that
he's just able to plow on through and
again that's why people that's why
people seem to be so seduced by it
people people are aghast but almost in
awe as well like a lot of the statuses
and tweets I've seen about there's a lot
of all in there of this guy well again
this is one this paradoxical thing some
human nature like everyone loves success
we also hate the people that are
successful but the idea of us being a
human engine of movement we're like you
never stop ever everyone in some level
like aspires to that if they had them if
they had the motivation to do that or if
they could only be that way you know how
much more would they get done but I mean
we also live in a culture where we
worship work you know that I rise that's
its own grain flex for the 1940s 30s
like sort of the greatest generation
where it's this cultural sentiment that
service taken over so the Western world
and I can't trace why it is I think it
started in the 30s 40s during like the
Great Depression during the stock market
crash where you had you know the world
economy had completed Neil service
collapse on itself
everyone was economically depressed and
the only way to survive you know this
was over 80 years ago 20 years ago
was it you had to work you had to work
otherwise you are getting nothing so I
like that I really believe like if I had
a pinpoint like where is the inception
of hustle and grind culture it was then
it was then and that would map that fall
that had followed the automation
revolution of the industrial air we're
now you can get so much work done
through automation you could leverage
per activity so you have this leveraging
of productivity and then you have this
crash and then you have the instinctual
and be the other predication of desire
where you have to work otherwise you're
not going to survive and that carries
over into World War two and then you
post-world war ii during like the at
least the united states boom and then
like you know how how do you rebuild
Europe we're gonna have to work to
rebuild the rubble literally have this
generation of people where they are
raised with that mindset and they
instill that and then they actually do
create a prepare prosperity it's 19 you
know 60s 70s 80s 90s you know overall
relatively speaking where if you worked
and you could get a job and you just you
put in the hours you would get something
in return
yeah and the more you work the higher
you would rise mmm
yeah but then you know then we get the
thing is though we it's like the era of
Technology late 1990s 2000s
and now with the admin of AI and the
admin of digital media the admin on
social platforms you could be working
hard and you're running faster and
faster to stay in the same place right
to the Red Queen effect for those people
you know that no they've got no models
yeah it's Red Queen trap so now your
hard work really doesn't mean much
because someone could be working less
than you but their work leverages way
more than yours does you at the same
time what if you work really hard and
it's all leverage to work too then
you're just like a god of work yes yeah
you are right it's an artifact of this
quite noble approach to work right when
you know that but now that we don't you
know coming back to the very beginning
of the conversation when you don't have
a job for life anymore we're choosing
choosing what is almost more important
than choosing how whereas in the past I
think how by any means would have
probably are you a hard worker yes when
you work in a factory when you're not a
knowledge worker essentially when IQ is
of a IQ I'm gonna get in trouble if I
say that when when your intellectual
capacity is less important
a lot of the promotion will be based on
seniority like well Bob's been here 50
years and John's been here 45 so Bob
gets the promotion even if John's maybe
a tiny little bit more competent because
that's the kind of the way that the
business is worked like a family or like
a like heirs to a kingdom almost like
the eldest brother gets it even if he's
a complete it and the the younger
brother would be a much better choice
but he's the older one so he gets it and
you have that noble approach to work but
now you no longer have the same lineage
moving forward where you can know that
you're gonna be staying in the same
place like you know it's a perfect
example self-driving cars like this why
is it between two and four million
workers I think I know 1 1 million
workers in America are what they call
professional drivers they like that is a
huge displacement of Labor yeah well I
think like uber is ultimate plan I think
with everyone driving the cars the data
they have this massive massive massive
massive database now of driving patterns
and vehicles yeah yeah well for having
cars that you think about the the US
economy like how much how much time gets
a lot its productivity gets lost from
people having to drive once you have
cars that can drive themselves ok well
now you have more time to work one but
you free up human capital like again so
like even you know that desire for
efficiency yeah but is that a bad thing
yeah I don't think so but I mean it's
it's interesting there all these things
surely create this confluence effect
yeah I think the seniority factor arises
from when workers artists it was like
artisanal it's like artisan work where
for most of human history you couldn't
really mass-produce anything like if you
did you just had to have a bunch of
people working on all at once and the
people were the best have been the
people that been working the longest
like that was probably up until 1800
that was most things before
mechanization to really took over
something that lies a craft yeah like
what yeah well like everything was
craftsmanship on certain level it
literally everything you know how much
you know what could you reproduce that
was just you know in 20 minutes you can
get done there's really nothing yeah but
then we get to the industrial area now
we eat the air machines and the machines
get digitized into computers and now you
can produce things you know within
minutes within seconds you can punch and
yeah like that you add 3d print like
that it's still in Tippin see but you
can type in a code and uh it just made
it for you and you don't have to do
anything yes it's the idea you even
coding itself is starting to change with
the effort machine learning you know
coding the idea like everyone learned to
code it's a ha ha ha kind of thing but
even like the language of coding now
they're getting simpler where you don't
even need to be able to code five years
no you don't have to code you'll just
type in what you'd like to have coded
and then the the AI will code it for you
it'll be like Squarespace for websites
but for coding like dress drag-and-drop
coding uh-huh well learn to code is not
gonna go down very well there is it but
look Alex man today has been awesome
I've really enjoyed it it's been an
awesome catch up listen I'd love I love
to have you back on I'm sure that a lot
of the listeners are gonna want you back
on as well deftly man have a good day
it's been sweet thank you
but that care
[Music]
you